welcome to film courage this is episode
149 my name is Karen worden and I'm
David Brannon you can find our archives
on itunes film curse calm la talk radio
calm and Mubi garage we are thrilled
that today we have with us on the line
director Tony Sierra and in studio actor
Chad Lindberg from the dock my big break
and if you've been anywhere around David
and myself for the past few months you
know that we've been telling everyone
about this film yeah we certainly assure
everyone we're telling about this so
this is a film you guys have to see um
it's formally entitled you know an
earlier version of the film is carving
out our name and that was back in 2001
it was abandoned after a whirlwind of
interest and then total silence on the
part of industry professionals so the
director Tony's era destroyed the film
and he left Hollywood yeah he then
returned to the film and not LA a few
years ago to resurrect a new version
calling it my big break
making it a slightly more telling
version about the real-life experience
of five aspiring artists living in a
house in the LA Miracle Mile district
back in the mid to late 90s director
Tony Sierra and for aspiring actors Chad
Lindberg Gregory Fossett West Bentley
and Brad Rowe all became roommates
around this time documenting for 10
years through video footage photos
narration from Tony's era shows four
young men from various parts of the US
who came the Los Angeles in search of an
acting career in stardom just like so
many people we know and three of the
roommates Chad Lindberg with us in
studio again at West Bentley and Brad
Rowe got that wish and then some my big
break shows the triumphs and struggles
of these men including Tony's own
rollercoaster ride with the business you
may know Chad from October sky the fast
nefarious and supernatural West Bentley
from American Beauty and the upcoming
The Hunger Games and Brad Roe from Billy
Billy's Hollywood screen kiss and
shelter we'd also like to extend our
thanks to the film's producer Elizabeth
Yaffe for all of her help in getting us
the film arranging this interview and
coordinating the excellent article by
Tony Sierra
entitled the final film courage and now
on film courage calm
please welcome to film courage via
telephone director Tony Zira and in
studio actor tad Limburg hello hello
hello welcome gentlemen thank you for
having us thank you for that wonderful
introduction
absolutely we've been super nervous they
couldn't come soon enough it could not
come soon
you know the stories of the five of you
who lived in this house that you
referred to as Maslin named after the
street where I was located so we're not
sure that even two shows would be able
to do this justice well you know even
before we get into a Karen you got it
you have you have your own Maslin story
yeah you have to tell this story yeah
it's funny how the universe works
because I was driving yesterday by LACMA
and I was kind of lost for a second and
I looked up and there's the street sign
Maslin and I was just like wow I
remember I called you I parked and I
called you to say what are the odds of
that and and I think I've passed through
the area before but something just I
mean it was surreal so yeah you know
what Chad was just telling us that
there's a sort of this magnetic force
with this house on Maslin you know for
those of you listening you guys can
connect with Chad on Twitter on Twitter
at Chad Lindberg and Tony at my big
break you can find us at film courage we
do read tweets on the air the hashtag
for the show is hashtag film courage and
you can follow it all along on tweet
chat calm all right well again thank you
gentlemen for joining us and we'll jump
right in
Tony in the movie we see that you were
roommates with these four then
undiscovered actors but we don't know
exactly how you guys came together was
it Craigslist was it fate did you put an
ad in the paper looking for roommates
how did this all transpire fate I mean
we I needed a place to live I think Chad
Matt was on this set my movie her on
yeah correct and and I met grey on a
small suit that I was doing and then and
Brad also and then I needed a place to
live Chad suggested maybe I should bring
the couch so everybody kind of you know
showed up from you know it's typical
lay house you know where somebody refers
someone and we just all became roommates
without knowing anything about the
documentary that it would actually take
place later on okay interesting and Chad
were these your first roommates have you
had prior roommates
yeah no these were my first roommates I
got there a while before everybody else
and Greg was actually there before
anybody and when I went there there were
a few other guys that were living there
and then over time they moved out and
eventually came Tony Brad and then Wes
and then that's when the house just kind
of took on a life of its own you know to
help set up this whole conversation
we're gonna try to focus on you a little
bit early here Todd just just to kind of
bring out a little bit more of your
story you know when you graduated high
school how soon was it before you move
to LA there's about a year after I
graduated high school and I knew I
wanted to come down here and you know
shoot for a career but I can I had to
wait you know for the right time and I
booked a movie in Seattle that come up
from LA called black circle boys and I
got in cast is one of the leads they
took a chance at a Northwest boy and got
the movie and as I was filming the movie
an agent from here that had a client a
movie came up and saw me and said when
you come to Los Angeles she'll be taken
care of and I came to LA right after I
was done shooting the flick I was 19 and
walked into a nice agency which is kind
of rare doesn't really happen
I definitely paid that price later on in
my career but at the time you know I
walked right into a really good
situation and was your goal to be a
working actor or really did you want to
be a star um I just I knew I wanted to
be an actor and I I knew I wanted
everything that came along with it I
just didn't know if that was gonna
happen or when but I just I just knew it
was gonna happen just something I always
knew okay that's what you know can you
expand on I mean did you have any doubts
you know like you know because I think
we're all young we come that way and we
all think we're special we all think we
have it yeah mm it was that was that a
strong part of your character at that
time you figured I'm coming here you
know that I have this city in my hand
I'm gonna make this happen
I rolled in a little cocky and a little
knowing which I think you kind of have
to to some degree I just knew it was
something I knew I was good at and I had
some success up in Seattle there was
just gonna be no stopping me
and that was just you know I put my
blinders on and just went to LA now I
look back I'm like man that was scary
what the heck am I thinking I'm glad it
worked out you know it was something
that kind of just new it's great how
youth has that I can remember doing the
same when I was 18 and and it's just
interesting how you just have no fear
whereas if you're in your mid-30s you'd
overthink it and worry about money and
yeah that's the beauty of youth Tony
it's really interesting in the movie
when Brad Rowe hits it big you point out
that the other roommates were of course
excited for Brad but at the same time
reality sets in that I think and this
happens to all of us really that then
the other guys felt like ooh what are
the odds of us making it if the one guy
in Maslin hits it big so and you see you
see kind of you know that they're happy
for him but didn't was there competition
between the rest of them after this I
mean what was the energy like between
the guys at that time once Brad is sort
of taking off well it's tough because
you know la is like super difficult and
so the odds of like having one guy in
the house
getting that big chance and is as we
mentioned in the movie it's like there's
a big difference weekend and fartin
getting you a break and so you know
people get parts but like in really the
big break and go into Sundance or
Toronto etc that was like okay this was
unheard of and so we were all like whoo
I guess this is it this is the only one
that is gonna get that break in the
house so I you know it obviously was
also really tougher on Greg because he
has Chad mentioned he was the first in
the house and so he had every time he
got her new roommate moves in they would
just get their break and it was very
intense for him so yeah I'm sure
also every time one of them got a movie
the others were like will like our movie
too so it's always always very
competitive and very supportive at the
same time it sees it also it's always
exciting to like have a friend in your
own house that has a big movie out and
you feel like oh wow you know it's like
it's possible but it's also frightening
because you may not get that chance okay
you know Jack yeah Jack can you expand
on that you know I mean were you
inspired by it by Brad you know in this
movie that's going to Sundance and just
sort of like all the acclaim that's
coming his way I mean were you inspired
did you feel competitive what was going
on at that time for you um yeah he had
had his moment there I mean we were all
working kind of you know so it wasn't
ever like competitive in the way like oh
my god I hate you like I can't believe
you like it was never competitive it was
a it we were supported each other and we
only help each other we built each other
up you know when we were like down and
we were happy for each other we really
were and we were so excited about all
the exciting stuff that was all of a
sudden happening to us and we had it we
looked at it with a sense of humor too
we weren't always serious about you
there weren't actors you know and but I
do think it was harder for Greg in a lot
of ways to see all of us go to these
huge premieres and you know it was tough
but uh you know we had a good time I
mean overall we weren't mad at each
other or anything like that no yes they
were very supportive it's you just see
the subtleties or I guess being behind
the camera too they you see just a sense
of frustration sometimes because you
know each is waiting for that part that
they want and so I would sometimes sense
there will be tension and it's all
dependent and sometimes there was
tension just because somebody else was
working it's because you're just waiting
and waiting right there were always
somebody was working it out yeah the
competition comes I think was yourself
at the end of the day yeah you know it
wasn't with the guys in the house
because there's no competing with any of
the guys in the house because Brad had
his thing was had his
Gregg has his thing I had my thing so
we're all very different I think that's
a great point too that you bring up Tony
that waiting because so much is in LA
you're waiting you're waiting for that
email that call and - I think you both
mentioned in Casey Ryan's interview that
how competitive LA is I mean you need a
headshot just to get a waiter job or a
bartending job I mean it's just it's in
it's totally competitive I'm wondering
what were your day jobs at this time all
the acting what were you guys doing you
know I mean was it was the acting you
know being able to carry you in those
obviously wasn't able to carry in the
early days so what would you guys turn
you know for filmmaking filmmakers like
we always laugh about this they're like
you really don't make money you spend
money and and and for filmmakers it's
like you know I had my own jobs on the
five the guys would work occasionally
probably I see Chad maybe mainly work
and Brett had worked at an agency like
in the mailroom for a while
I think Chad you delivered food right
yeah yeah when I first moved to LA I
delivered Italian food for two weeks and
then I booked Buffy and then that was it
luckily delivery drivers like my worst
would like telemarketing because I was
summoned plastic gloves to do hospitals
and and I think they made me promise
whoever would buy like the nurse to get
a free box of chocolate and it was part
of a scam I discovered later on people
weren't getting their chocolate then it
was just horrible because it's it
they're like you know did the same
speech every day I like please buy a box
of gloves and you'll get a free box of
CCK me or something like that and you
know but I need all kinds of jobs and
and you know work that labels are mining
Duff's and you know just kept floating
along with having garage sales just keep
the movie going tonight can I add some
think what kind of world do we live in
where somebody doesn't get their
chocolates
you know I want to throw in there I mean
I mean that in itself is really
remarkable in LA for two weeks you know
see I mean you have a day job for two
weeks and you booked this role I mean
that in itself is so remarkable how
crucial was that I mean if if you don't
book that role early on I mean do you do
you see a entirely different course you
know coming your way because you know on
one level it's like people get a chance
to literally just see you as an actor
they don't see you as anything else they
just see you as an actor how crucial was
that um I guess looking back at it now
that it you know I feel very lucky they
did work out I you know I did I got
Buffy and then like a month later I
booked a a two spot on ER which was a
pretty big deal and then it just kept
snowballing from there so you know it
wasn't till like 10 years down the road
that I really sort of had to like go
backwards a little bit and at this time
I was famous so it really you know
stirred up a whole different set of
challenges crazy hours you know it was
really unusual I think how much time and
money did you spend on acting classes
yeah okay um I did not acting in high
school and did plays and then I hadn't
taken never I've never taken an acting
class until a couple like three years
ago
I searched somebody out my name is
Margie Valentine and she's absolutely
awesome she's an acting coach and you
know cuz my stick uh you know you get to
a point as an actor where you're well it
dries up and you need to challenge
yourself and push so I started taking
classes and you know working on my craft
but until that point I never and and
what about the other guys in the house
uh West went to Juilliard
and he dropped out right I think so yeah
yeah and then Brad Tony what did yeah he
did take some class like that well like
on and off but he was no he was just
discovered that they're in a room yeah
at UTA and he was just reading scripts
and he's somebody like Solomon said hey
we think you got something and that was
it was really you know and then and Greg
of course went to USC
he studied theater and drama so
everybody was you know doing their it
was really strange for this house
because at the same time I you know I
had a lot of friends in LA that I knew
we're trying it that you know we're like
living in different areas and it was
just very strange to see the house just
constantly people just booking parts
getting like really major roles and I
think that was once everybody started to
work it was just a big complete change
and it really threw me off
it was super shocking and not because I
was just doing the movie it just it was
really really unheard of
one after the other it was like it got
to a point where I would meet people on
the Strand block what is this one doing
what is what's the secret and I'm like I
have to work what secret it's very
strange
you know I mean it's part of the secret
the fact that I mean even though you
guys weren't going to acting class I
mean you know here you are you are this
this documentary is being made I mean
you know Tony tony has a camera he's
filming you guys have been in a sense
that's sort of your acting class R
acting school I mean is that how you
view those early days I mean how often
was the camera rolling
Cameron was always performing like they
were always my like non-stop you like
short films and everybody was like like
Mimi it was done on camera whether it
was for God there's a documentary or not
I mean don't forget I have like over 200
hours of footage since and and you know
it was so it was so difficult to just
like kind of let go of almost hundred
and ninety eight hours and just keep an
hour and a half of the film at the end
it was really tough to at it but at the
same time
there was so much stuff that wasn't even
part of the documentary that is just
people would reenact other movies they
would be play they would dance they
would jump off the roof I we were just
constant so much I was a little small
independent mini studio running all the
time and yeah you know it makes me
wonder what was it a shared experience I
mean Tony are you literally filming
these guys and you know and obviously
the performers are they going back and
are they critiquing the work a minute
are you guys having sort of like viewing
parties and laughing and having fun in
that sense no it kind of guard in a way
of life because I didn't know where the
stuff was going so I would just film
stuff and just keep it aside but then we
also had I think the first job chat got
an acting gig he bought a camera like a
small video camera or like a well I
don't have to keep renting and and so
this camera just get started getting
bounced from like West with film Chad
with film and just constantly so
sometimes we would sit and watch like
the goofy stuff with it or the little
short films but as far as the stuff for
the actual documentary occasionally you
would look at it but I was kind of a
little sensitive about the stuff that I
would sometimes say beside at what point
did you know okay I have a movie here
cuz I think you you kind of wrestled
with the fact that you couldn't figure
out maybe what you wanted to film and
then at some point you realized this is
it this is what I want to film well to
be honest there were two things going on
one is I was even though everybody was
so supportive I was worried that they
would just get tired like they would be
like turn your camera off because this
is like when are you gonna be done like
because I didn't remember it's like if
somebody who is happy okay you can get
away with it and turn off the cameras
about rolling but when it was when there
was a little tension if somebody's going
through something tough I had this fear
and that was only my personal thing that
they would say okay you know what no I
don't want this on camera or you're
pushing it now so I had that one side of
it and then the other side was
it's almost like I thought really
everybody was gonna leave like that was
my because it's all the friends that you
know that I met in LA that like there
was always really a lot of broken dreams
but people always were working to you
know so I didn't know if I was going to
film everybody's just going home
including myself or it's just gonna you
know when wanted worked I figured what
this is it is that the one guys and
that's it and then it's in the second
and I was surprised and the third and it
really threw me off and I was like you
kidding I was so excited so you really
for me I was very selfish I just wanted
it to go on forever and ever I keep
capturing as much as like that actually
Tony I wanna I mean I mean cuz you say
that you say like you thought the end of
this story the end of this movie is
gonna be that each of these guys is
gonna pack their bags and go home I mean
did you ever did you ever share those
feelings with the guys like I mean was
that ever discussed about thank you
unspoken I think we all like again it's
a tough business so we were like you
know Brad Brad did mention to me call
the sensitiveness and you know what I'm
giving this five years if it doesn't
happen I'm leaving and I'm like are you
kidding and he's like yeah this is he's
very you know if he had really their
their concept and the way they lived
life and Brad was very practical his
life this is a I'm gonna do this for
five years and that's it Greg on the
other hand is he saw in the film he said
I'm taking this to the toilet so you had
really different yes the personality
that is so the spectrum is just so wide
and that's what made it so interesting
to keep them in these guys you just
couldn't get enough Tony at the heart of
it how much was it that these guys
wanted to be famous in your opinion
versus wanting to be professional actors
and what is the fine line that separates
the two things each is different again
so it's hard to answer the question like
so I was like you know breaking it down
for each person but I really truly what
I saw it is that there was two groups
one group would like be really
interested in you know like Jeff could
speak for himself
but I know that Chad likes to perform
he's just used to get very excited of
him he's in front of the camera
what's love to analyze breath just have
fun with it but he also but again at the
end of the day they all want it to work
so but also in the beginning they were
when they spotted work in their minds
that was different than later on so I
think it's almost like you grew as an
artist or as an actor and they saw the
arc of growth so it's like in the
beginning I would I would like capture
moments with them or they're like they
just want to have fun and then it would
get to another point where you start to
hear no this is about my craft and then
it would get to another plan and it's
like I need a big role or I need to be
more of a very intense character actor
it was always changing and so that's
really my answer so it's really hard to
like sum up with like who won and what
were they were they were always again
ten years so it's like you can imagine
like yeah different yeah people change a
lot in ten years and we were just
driving over here thinking there's so
many people in this town that want the
glory of it and then there's just a
small percentage it seems like that are
willing to put in the work we're just
talking about that yeah
I've seen it's almost like really what I
appreciate it from the guys and I think
mainly Chad and West End to do that more
on their own where again I go back to
everybody's different we had almost like
our own group of like constantly filming
each other and like just going out there
and trying different things
greg was more he had more of a almost a
methodical way of doing things he was
only focused on auditions but at the
same time also extremely distracted and
and that's why I love the characters in
the movie and it's a look at his
characters aside from being like best
friend and then you had Brad it's almost
he was a businessman yeah so it was very
interesting to see their approach and
the consequences of that later on we can
I think in my home where they you think
it's a
scene yeah we're gonna be on the movie
no are you thinking the roof I'm
thinking the one where he's at Sundance
and he's just like you know I got people
back in LA working for me you know here
we are I think things are happening at
Sundance oh I got people back in LA
where where are you gonna say I love the
scene where Brad's on the roof getting
his but this photo shoot and then and
Greg so it looks like he's just woken up
and his hairs and he's just like yeah
you know I think this is a good moment
to turn to you chat because you've
worked with a lot of actors you know and
you know and you've seen them at all
different stages of their careers in
terms of maybe the very beginning you
know how often have you been in a
position where maybe you're working with
a young actor who really at that point
in time it's more about the fame rather
than just doing the work I mean do you
pull them aside do you have any
discussions with them if you did what
would you say to them um you know when
I'm on set I kind of mind my own
business
you know I think everyone is in it for a
different reason and you know there are
those Hollywood people that come across
and you know I just kind of let them be
I don't really have much to say I know
why I'm in it you know if I were to pull
them over they're like what are you
doing stop like no one cares like I
don't know like some people take
themselves way too seriously and you
just enacted that's it it's not you know
and and and you've worked with you know
just you know just name after name you
know you've worked with a lot a lot a
lot of working act there's a lot of
well-known actors you know what are you
seeing them you know where do you see in
terms of what their mindset is when
they're on set you know what do you gain
from being around some of the folks
you've worked with just how you how to
carry yourself you know professionalism
you know and working hard I mean working
hard it's it's it's you know you're on
set for 12 14 hours sometimes and it's
it's a lot of work so you know I like to
watch people and how they handle it how
they handle the set how they handle Fame
how they
and the crew I think it's all very
important and I think at this level you
need to be respectful to your fellow
actors into your crew and to everybody
because it's totally a huge blessing to
be able to work in this town so you know
if you're in that level man just be cool
we have actor Chad Lindberg in studio
director Tony Zira on the line we're
talking about their film my big break
you know Chad how often was Tony
following you around or me was he
following you around on auditions I mean
you know how often when you leave the
house and follow you guys cuz here's the
thing I can't help but think this it's
like you guys are young actors I mean
obviously we know the result you know of
sort of like the status you guys reached
I just wonder is the fact that you guys
were having this documentary made those
cameras following around was that sort
of influence or you think in any way I'm
just I'm trying to come up with some
sort of explanation or reason and it
just you know la is is the kind of city
where like everyone you know whether you
be at a party or just you're out
somewhere it every is always like
looking around like who's here right and
do you think the fact that this camera
was always around was a factor I don't
know that it was a factor I mean because
we were actors and we're always hamming
it up in front of the camera we were
always trying to push each other into
outdoing each other as you see in a
movie um I mean we were crazy and and
and you know Tony always had a camera
you turn around he'd be like there
please I'm filming you Tony voice and
but it was cool you know and we all
understood back in the day that I think
this was a going to be a tool that was
used down the line for actors or people
that wanted to come to LA or I I don't
know we just I you know I don't think it
really I don't know I'm used to cameras
so and so was everybody else you know
Tony Tony how many auditions did you go
on with these guys I mean were you a
presence or you just kind of like let
them do this thing no no I didn't go in
many auditions and here's ironically why
they just started working and it was
like there was like it's been a very how
can explain it was like in the beginning
I thought half of my Cherie will be
about of the auditions but then once
they took off they were just like the
scripts were coming to the door and they
were just getting offers and it wasn't
really so of course like if your
auditions were like our you know I just
wasn't allowed to go if I'm not gonna go
talk to those Joel Schumacher that I had
things is they have to come in be on the
auditions but auditions kind of
disappeared it was very strange like I
remember I thought I would like follow
what's for a while about auditions etc
and it's like once you got American
Beauty that's it you could just pick
whatever he wants so it's kind of really
changed and sometimes you know I knew
that I tried to steal it for my dishes
as much as possible too because they
were always out like you mentioned there
was always other actors sitting there
waiting I actually the ones I shot would
actually I would know the filmmakers and
I would just be inside or I just get the
tape and so that would that made it much
easier for me you know Tony um on the
other side of all this you know the film
got into to the Toronto National Film
Festival and you had distributors and
and and just very all kinds of people in
Hollywood sort of fighting over the film
but I want to touch on September 10th
2001 how much do you remember of that
night and what can you tell us about
September 10 2001 everything I mean
that's what changed everything
it was very because it was it was the
high of highs in there
the next news the lows lows it was just
very it was very it was an intense
experience so can you can you can you
paint the picture for so you know what
exactly happened on September 10th what
happened before that the whole deal well
basically this screening the big
premiere was scheduled for September
10th that night we had a premiere and I
thought we might have
you know a couple of hundred people
there was almost like a thousand people
in there and so there was a big theater
oh is like were received dragged it's
almost like you know Greg literally he
arrives that night yeah it was his
stand-up comedy night he like stood up
in front of audience and he just kept
cracking jokes people loved the movie
and they had to actually like to get out
of it here after the Q&A because just
went on and on and then we had an
after-party which I couldn't even get
into which I give it's your own after
party yeah I got to the door and then
it's funny when you're actually in LA
and you're going oh what should we call
the movie carving out our name I have
this concept in my head and then finally
- here comes to the door and then they
say this is the party for carving our
name are you on the list
and you're like going oh no it's like
I'm the filming sir you're gonna have an
unlike okay this is a joke because so
then I stood by the door and I hear like
I would see people come up to their
sister bouncers or whatever you want to
call them and they're gone
I know carbon on him I'm with the actors
and people that we didn't even know and
so everybody was trying to get in the
party including like I went in there was
Mark Wahlberg who was their agent songs
own you know it's how weird this little
thing that started at the house it
suddenly now has a premiere party and so
and so if you know so to make a long
story short we went to the party and I
didn't want to close the deal that night
I didn't want any money then I I didn't
want to do any business that night there
was at the time I felt like it was lay
it was the first night I figured let's
just tackle this in the morning I want
it to be more whatever words stupid or
like very fun sentiment or whatever you
want to call it I figured this was just
about the friend everybody was very open
they let me capture their life etc and I
said I just wanna do business till the
morning and and I don't think my
decision
really affected anything whatever was
going to happen that night or the
morning was gonna you know I don't think
anyone can hand me a check at night but
and the agents were ready to you know
catch you now as I mentioned in article
he was wrapping the movie and he said
that you know people really interested
there were offers coming in but yes
we're not gonna do any deals finance
that great and met everyone and I heard
that night there from someone that Mark
Wahlberg was actually has this concept
in his mind which I was discovered it
was entourage and he was there looking
around and so I was Michael desperate I
met him I said hello Fox whatever and
and everybody just had a good time I
went back to the hotel I think I slept
for like maybe an hour I would actually
know I took I took a taxi and left the
party because I was starting to freak
out I just couldn't believe that the
movie was done and that I would actually
like have a movie done and like be
looked at like baby a filmmaker like
that dreamer so so I had to really like
get away for like half an hour because I
was really like over well and and then
when I came back and I think they called
me in the morning there was the
publicist and Elizabeth Yaffe the
producer she she called an orange she
said watch TV and of course I turned it
on the TV and they all I saw was like
you know smoke coming out of a building
I didn't really know what was happening
and they were like sounded like they
don't want to go to the screening we had
the press screening in the morning and
um and I thought they were like pulling
something on me as if like they don't
want to work hard or whatever so that I
got away what are you talking about you
better be down there and so I went down
there to the press screening I opened
the door and there was literally one
person in the theater and so of course I
went crazy so then I went upstairs
looked on the sidewalk and it's
literally the entire sidewalk was people
and cell phones crying and and then
that's when I heard that it was a
passenger plane because I thought it was
a Holocaust or plate if the windows or
something and now and when I saw that I
was like that was it we all like kind of
completely forgot about the movie they
announced that they shut down the
festival which they did resumed on the
last day I believe
and just lucky no life completely
changed and and in that following night
our agent said that we were going to
have dinner there was like sony sony
classic was there and a couple of other
distributors that maybe you could talk
to the actors and everybody said let's
donate some if we do the sale will
donate some percentage to the cause are
just like because of the catastrophes in
New York etc but I didn't think that was
gonna affect the movie but we also we
were thinking movie anymore and then
there he kind of died down and it seemed
like that cassian wanted to just people
left and then I'm sure you remember they
started to say well that people that
counts were that the whole the whole
industry has been affected their buyers
left town etc so he said let's pick this
up in LA when we get back and and then
we all left and that was it just just to
help set it up here Tony you know
leading up to the premiere or you know
that this whole premiere what kind of
advice what kind of people did you have
around the film like you know leading up
to it you know you said you didn't want
to make a deal that night who did you
have in your ear and kind of what would
advice were you being given well I was
being given that I was told that
basically will sell you know as the
breaker in territories some people were
saying we'll sell domestic and hold on
to foreign all will sell foreign and
hold on to domestic because that's where
the money is and so you had a lot of
people that were interested to buy
different territories but we also want
it I was more not in class I wanted to
do something or MTV or someone that
would actually have this as because of
just the age group and like you thought
the time that was a big thing about
reality when I started filming remember
it wasn't really like talked about much
you know people who is very author like
oh you're gonna follow your friend and
so by then by 2001 it was sparse
kind of be very interesting thing about
like oh you really had acted access to
actors etc so we thought at one point in
that catchin wanted to go with MTV but
then was Miramax was there some people
wanted to buy foreign they were also
independent distributors that wanted to
put in all the money take all the
foreign rights and leave the domestic
aside till we get back so there was just
all kinds of deals floating around my
concern was that I didn't want you know
as a we've all heard the stories that
they were gonna take the movie and recut
it so I was kind of animated like that
you're not going to do that because so I
wanted to review whoever was going to
give us a deal I wanted to make sure
that they not going to really change the
film ami you know I was worried that
they may say well three are known let's
cut the unknown guy you know you know
whatever you know did you know so I was
really more kind of cautious like I
wanted to sit down and hear what the
distributor was planning to do with the
movie and that was that it seems like a
lot of the calls and and communication
just pretty much came to a stop why is
it this film is so sort of in the dark
because we believe so much in it and we
tell everybody we know about it is it
blacklisted does Hollywood not want you
know well general public to see it great
question which a long time to keep
thinking about that ass around a lot and
what happened is this in the industry
wasn't really interested in the
documentary before so that was it's
Roger once it went to Toronto
you just couldn't stop it and and
industry suddenly we wanted to be part
of it and they just overnight they were
fighting about wrapping the movie I know
it's from see a toy or Morris etc and I
was aware of that that I know that this
is this was happening because of the
buzz and I did can offer that people
want to talk about like other movies in
the future I was like let's just focus
this should sell this movie and we'll
see what happened and then once that
heat died down in Toronto and the movie
came here and LA I think this would luck
industries while
the movie and I think it's almost like
they were nervous I still go back to the
time where like West's people at the
time were really little tense about the
movie and I don't think it was really
the movie I think it's also where West
was at the time what I mean by that is
that he was he was through a darker
period of who's going there I guess and
that just kind of called too much
attention to today I would assume and
and that's what I would call back and I
would ask for my friend today they lost
my friends at one point and then out
Spana
yeah my calls returned and there was
just a lot of chaos other agents wanted
to finish the deal they wouldn't let
them take the deal and finish it and
then I would call back again and they
would say well I don't know I'm sitting
with them in the meeting in there
looking worse in the morning and they
would sit together and then the other
agent would say I would like to run with
this there are deals out there and they
would just call me back and say he just
doesn't want to talk about it and that's
catching and I just never heard from him
I mean it's so shocking to be a
filmmaker right and go to a festival
have an agent etc etc and everybody is
like he was he was obsessed with the
movie and then like suddenly just no one
wants to talk to you
it was really throw me off and I felt
like there was just pressure possibly
pressure on Kashian at the time nobody
really ever like came back and explained
what happened all I know is that what
the pages was at the screening at the
time he watched the movie
he was extremely tense they don't want
to talk to me walked out and and so
today man I was too exposing but the
people let's say like Chad or I'll say
Chavez chatted you know I mean he's
there he can tell you but he's been so
he always saw as a learning tool and a
teaching tool innocence so like he
wanted people see what I was like that
was my intention from the beginning that
all the guys actually felt and saw it
that way but you know again we were all
surrounded by agents and managers that
like we may have a certain thought one
more
but the agents and the measure doesn't
cease that way and so they would step in
and be with you know including what's
his manager which is defined was lee
daniels who's the director now he was
gonna run with the movie and then again
he disappears so it would like how it's
being bounced from one person to another
and hope that they would sell the movie
and then time just kept going going
going going and nothing has happened
nothing has happened and we all know
that it's like when you get to that feel
like when you get to this period were
like actually five is running and no one
is calling you known as giving you a
straight answer yeah you know what that
means let me throw on this question you
know you know cuz we're coming down to
our final five minutes here so we're
gonna try to pack in some more stuff
chitchat is it possible to sustain an
acting career
in Los Angeles if you don't have a
so-called big break of some kind you
know cuz I'm in my right that you have
to get something to pop you have to be
working you have to have perseverance I
think you have to have some talent to
back it up to continue working to have
that you know to go the distance over
the years you definitely have to have
some talent I think and yeah having
those pops along the way it you know
doesn't hurt you know I mean it's it's
it's nice to have those those those mile
markers along the way you know that sort
of like take you to that next level
hopefully but everyone's different you
know everyone has a different you know
you could be Shia LaBeouf and have every
major movie handed to when you're 19 but
he was in it you know since he was a you
know young so it's just you know or you
could be in your 50s and have your big
break and you know everyone's different
I've had a steady burn which in the long
run is the way to go for me you know you
kind of you don't get too ahead of
yourself yeah and you have this one
especially great scene in the movie
where you're talking about when you're
like 18 or 19 year having all this great
work thrown at you and
don't realize kind of what you have you
know and just as we wrap up here can you
talk about what life was like when stuff
wasn't as easy when work wasn't coming
your way I think you had to move out of
your place yeah and some really
traumatic stuff happened yeah
gosh it was how long ago was no eight
years ago no gosh I don't know yeah
there came a time I couldn't afford rent
anymore things just got way out of hand
I had a lot of you know financial issues
that we just got on top of me I had to
move out of my house I moved back home
for a little bit with my folks and I had
to kind of like work it out I got a
little cabin on the lake and back home
with up in Washington and just sorted it
out for a little while and then I came
back to LA and just sort of like you
know built up my you know confidence
again but um yeah it was a tough time
but you know it builds character and I
think you all need to go through the ups
and the downs to appreciate you know
when things do happen you appreciate it
that much more and what was it that's
well what is it that's different about
now so you've went through that dark
time and so what do you think it is now
where it's it's gonna be different you
think just being older or or just having
been through sort of life's challenges
what what is it I think yeah having gone
through all that I've been here a while
now so you know nothing really surprises
me too much yeah just you know yeah I
think being here as many years ya know
you know Tony you know this I guess we
just finally you Tony you know cuz after
this movie didn't take off you know your
life just basically collapsed in front
of you there you know and you also
reached rock bottom with this project
can you just just can you touch on how
you sort of put the pieces back together
how you got your life back on track from
from the very from the pinnacle from the
mountaintop you know to just falling on
your face there well I definitely
allowed to figure out what to do and
then I realize you know
my conclusion of like in the sense of
how I could do this was like to reset I
had to completely reset off from the
beginning na and I you know that's what
my own demons and like to try to like
get myself in more of a clear place and
then looked at the movie as if I've
never worked on a single day and that
nothing happens with it and they just
basically looked at it as like brand-new
footage sitting in the box and the
difference this time was is very
actually put my own story in the movie
because I wasn't in carving I never
appeared in carving or said a single
word in carving and so in this one so
then I thought it just from scratch I
started editing and they just wanted to
tell the story completely from beginning
to end including my own and and I define
like you know it was much easier we had
Final Cut so I was able to have my own
studio at home I could have as many
drives as they want and put all the
footage on it and I didn't have to do
this offline online thing which drove me
crazy when I was editing in 2001 and and
I just went for it and I edited the
movie and it was just it was actually
more liberating to actually be able to
tell him in my own story and be just put
myself also out there just as much as
the guys and and I just finished it and
and now it's my big break no I don't
mean my big break I mean the movie you
know and we're overjoyed you know
overjoyed that you yet that you stuck it
out you know ten years on the same
project the same film it's something you
know we can all admire you know the
curve that you that you've shown here
and getting this done it's a leave LA
and then yeah yeah and then overcome you
can't overcome
yeah it's really important to me and I
felt like because when I went to LA I
would like go to every library and video
store and just try to find like anything
that could learn from and I would listen
as will filmmakers an actress we
listened to like the the audio track on
a DVD cetera the commentary and I would
you know I'm so happy to just have this
thing were like you could literally sit
and watch the reaction of each person in
the movie the decisions they make
the lessons and and I water also the
story with respect for filmmakers to
feel like that's what you're gonna hear
that's what people will tell you and
even if everything falls apart and it's
all destroyed you still can get back on
again and do what you wanted to do and
just keep that dream going because it
really only ends when you let it end and
so that was really a good story for me
to tell and I have to still again
mentioned you know when Jeff Holden told
me that he that you died that was also
another point where I felt like I had to
he know this we just all get caught up
in that business is you know and it's
very it's almost like a mistake ground
isn't clear and just stay healthy and
and just keep trying because you don't
no one stops no one's stopping you the
only one gonna stop yourself
we love the conversation and we will
plainly say to everyone listening to
this each of you listening you have to
see this movie there's no way you can
listen to film Kurds and not see my big
break it's a movie you have to see we've
been speaking with director Tony teairra
an actor Chad Lindberg from the
documentary my big break you can find
out more about Tony Chad and my big
break at my big break movie calm at my
big break on Twitter my big break on
Facebook and of course at SATA Limburg
on Twitter yeah and thanks again guys
for your time today I mean we really
want more people watching the film and
talking about it and you can you can
find it on dystrophy and also amazon.com
and there's also direct links to those
sites on the website my big break calm
and again we'd like to extend our thanks
to the film's producer Elizabeth Yaffe
for all her help in arranging this
interview
absolutely thank you guys for having us
and being such a huge yeah oh thank you
well thank you thank you and thank you
for everyone listening and a special
shout out to the supernatural fans who
come in droves
you guys thank you guys thank you very
much and to all of you out there
listening have a great week